UNDERSTATEMENT AND THE TIME HAS
COME FOR YOU TO RESIGN.
>> Julie: BRIAN MAAS IS A
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE FOREIGN
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE AND ALSO A
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR TALKING TO US.
LET'S TALK ABOUT MAYORKAS'S
WORDS.
HE SAYS UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
WERE PROMPTLY REMOVED IF THEIR
CLAIMS DON'T PREVAIL.
THE "WASHINGTON POST" IN FACT
SAYS THE OPPOSITE THAT ONE
MILLION PEOPLE WHO ENTERED THE
COUNTRY WITHOUT PROPER
DOCUMENTS HAVE BEEN GIVEN
DEPORTATION ORDERS AND THEY
STILL HAVE NOT LEFT.
SO THE QUESTION IS DOES
MAYORKAS SUFFER FROM FUZZY MATH
OR FLAT OUT LYING?
>> LET'S TAKE THE SENTENCE
BEFORE THAT ONE AS WELL.
THEY WILL IMMEDIATELY BE PLACED
INTO IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT
PROCEEDINGS.
THAT'S TRUE.
AND WHAT ARE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S VERSION OF
PROCEEDINGS?
TAKE THEM INTO THE COUNTRY BY A
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS UNDER
HOMELAND.
PUT THEM ON A BUS AND GIVE THEM
HEALTHCARE AND SEND THEM
SOMEWHERE ELSE AROUND THE
COUNTRY TO APPEAR AT A COURT
DATE STIMULATES IN THE FUTURE
MAYBE TWO OR THREE YEARS IN THE
FUTURE OR NEVER.
THAT'S WHAT IMMEDIATELY PLACED
INTO IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT
PROCEEDINGS ACTUALLY LOOKS LIKE.
HE IS NOT LYING, HE IS JUST NOT
TELLING YOU THE TRUTH THERE.
WHERE HE STARTS TO LIE IS TO
SAY IT'S PROMPT.
IT IS NOT.
>> Julie: DEFINITION WOULD BE
NOT TELLING THE TRUTH.
WHO AM I TO SAY?
CRITICS.
>> THE GUY IN CHARGE OF
DISINFORMATION GOVERNANCE
BOARD, THE HEAD OF THAT.
>> I LOVE THAT TITLE
MISINFORMATION BOARD.
THEY CORNER THE POLICY ON
MISINFORMATION.
CRITICS OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION BORDER POLICY
SAY THEIR ABANDONMENT OF ICE
DETENTION CENTERS ARE CALLED
ALTERNATIVES TO DEFENSE.
ONLY EXACERBATING AN ONGOING
CRISIS AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
LUMP THAT IN WITH THE
POSSIBILITY OF THE ERADICATION
OF TITLE 42 LATER THIS MONTH
AND WHAT DO YOU GET?
>> YOU GET THIS PROBLEM.
LET ME BRING YOU TO SOMETHING
THAT HAPPENED LAST WEEK.
I SIT ON THE FOREIGN AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE AND GET A LOT OF
DELEGATIONS FROM FOREIGN
COUNTRIES, MEMBERS OF
PARLIAMENT, SECRETARIES OF
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THEIR
GOVERNMENT, YOU NAME IT.
I HAD A DELEGATION IN FROM
GUATEMALA GAS WEEK INTO MY
OFFICE AND BLAMING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION FOR WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THEIR COUNTRY.
THE COYOTES COME ON TV AND RUN
ADS SAYING IF YOU GIVE US
$5,000, $10,000 LOOK AT THIS
ADD OF WHAT JOE BIDEN IS SAYING.
WE CAN GET YOU INTO THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA NO QUESTIONS
ASKED.
THIS IS WHAT THE GUATEMALAN
DELEGATION IS TELLING US THE
PROBLEM AND WHAT IS BEING AIRED
ON THEIR TV.
THIS PROBLEM IS GOING ACROSS
BORDER BECAUSE OF JOE BIDEN.
>> Julie: THERE IS A RECENT
POLYWANT L -- POLL I WANT TO
PUT ON THE SCREEN.
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS SAY IT IS
NOT THE RIGHT TIME TO END THE
TITLE 42 POLICY.
MOST AMERICANS, 57%, SAY NOW
THE NOT TO TIME TO END TITLE 42
BORDER POLICY.
OF ALL TIMES TO END THIS THING,
WHY NOW?
WHAT ARE THEY TRYING TO PROVE?
>> THIS IS THE ONLY COVID
POLICY THAT DEMOCRATS WANT TO
GET RID OF IS THE ONE THAT
KEEPS PEOPLE FROM COMING INTO
AMERICA ILLEGALLY.
THE ONLY ONE THEY WANT TO GET
RID OF.
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU
CONTINUE TO WEAR MASKS, KICKED
OUT OF THE MILITARY IF YOU
DON'T GET A VACCINE STILL AND
OTHER THINGS LIKE THAT.
THE ONLY THING THEY WANT TO GET
RID OF.
WHY?
THEY BELIEVE IN OPEN BORDERS,
IN LETTING PEOPLE COME ACROSS
THOSE BORDERS WITHOUT GETTING A
COVID TEST OR ANYTHING ELSE,
WITHOUT WORRYING ABOUT THE
DRUGS THEY BRING ACROSS, THE
FENTANYL, HUMAN TRAFFICKING,
SEX TRAFFICKING.
EVERYTHING ELSE.
IT IS AN AMERICA LAST POLICY.
EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT
DONALD TRUMP HAD IN PLACE WITH
AMERICAN FIRST POLICIES REMAIN
IN MEXICO.
IT'S WHERE THAT PARTY IS AT.
PEOPLE TRY TO UNDERSTAND WHY
WOULD THEY DO THIS?
IT'S WHERE THEIR PARTY IS AT.
THE PARTY OF OPEN BORDERS.
THAT'S IT.
>> Julie: YOU OPEN THE BORDER,
THEY WILL COME AND DIE HERE.
AS YOU KNOW YOU'VE SEEN
REPORTING HERE ON THIS CHANNEL
HOW MIGRANTS ARE DROWNING BY
THE DOZENS, BY THE HUNDREDS.
PEOPLE BEING KILLED OR LOSING
THEIR LIVES BY COMING INTO THIS
COUNTRY.
WE'RE ALLOWING IT TO HAPPEN.
A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS TO SAY
THE VERY LEAST.
CONGRESSMAN MAAS, TH